[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors moi j'ai complètement foiré mes
études à l'âge de 19 ans on m'a
gentiment remerciée de la prépa de
polytechnique dans laquelle j'étais
parce que je passais mon temps à faire
du snowboard et je pense que ça a énervé
tout le monde parce que j'arrivais en
peu en buttes de snow à la fac est en
tout cas mes notes n'étaient pas assez
bonnes donc je me suis fait expulser
parce que j'avais une passion dévorante
pour le snowboard
tout ce que je voulais c'était faire du
snowboard l'hiver sur la neige l'été sur
les glaciers à tel point que moi je
débarquais de paris et je voulais
rentrer dans cette culture du snowboard
voulais faire partie de cet univers
culturel la famille du snowboard et j'ai
commencé à faire des photos en numérique
avec l'appareil que mon père m'a offert
et je voulais devenir photographe de
snowboard c'était mon ma passion ultime
c'est de devenir sa et sauf qu'au départ
j'avais pas d'amis qui était fort en
snowboard et alors j'ai commencé mes
premières photos à faire des photos de
moi même avec un trépied je mettais un
trépied je prenais une télécommande et
paf
aux moments importants claque j'appuie
sur la télécommande on peut voir là
[Musique]
et c'est comme ça que j'ai fait mes
premières photos et je voulais j'étais
très passionné je voulais je courais
partout dans tous les sens avec ma
petite voiture et je voulais apprendre
toutes les techniques numériques les
flash est tous vraiment et petit à petit
je me suis rendu compte que de plus en
plus mon style de photos se rapprocher
des idoles que j'avais des photographes
que j'admirais beaucoup et le musée mais
ça sert à rien que mes photos
ressemblent aux autres alors par
curiosité j'ai commencé à faire de
l'argentique et mes premières photos en
argentique
elle me semblait complètement différent
des photos des autres et les premières
photos que je voyais il y avait des
défauts il ya des entrées de lumière il
y avait des problèmes qui rendait que la
photo était unique on pouvait on pouvait
l'additionner parmi les autres mais
surtout ce qui m'a le plus convaincu
c'est le grain noir et blanc vraiment
pour moi le grain c'était génial parce
que c'était plus vraiment une photo ça
ressemble vachement plus à un dessin et
c'est ça qui a captivé mon attention et
qui m'a donné le goût de faire de la
photo en une en argentique et à partir
de ce moment là j'ai pu jamais voulu
faire de photo numérique et c'était
vraiment tous les petits défauts liés à
la pellicule qui me donnait le plus de
satisfaction est alors ensuite
logiquement je me suis mis à faire du
laboratoire et je voulais apprendre à
faire les tirages dans la chambre noire
mais j'avais personnes pour m'apprendre
j'ai donc pas été aux beaux-arts nez
dans les écoles de photos est alors au
début je savais même pas comment allumer
la lampe de l'agrandisseur toi et je
faisais mes premières photos et je
m'étais la feuille dans la bassine et la
feuille sorte est toute blanche ou tout
noir
jusqu'au jour où à force de tâtonner ben
j'ai pu faire apparaître les premières
photos
et c'était une satisfaction énorme parce
que sans utiliser l'ordinateur
j'arrivais à produire ces images moi
même est ce que j'aimais le plus dans
ces photos c'est que on pouvait zoomer
indéfiniment dedans on trouvait jamais
de pixels si on zoome de plus en plus on
trouve au contraire des molécules les
sels d'argent qui constitue la
photographie est alors j'ai développé un
peu mon style comme ça ça m'a permis de
me démarquer des autres photographes
est ce que j'affectionnais le plus c'est
les petites erreurs par exemple ici la
ja il ya un problème de chimie qui a mal
coulé dans le truc je sais pas
exactement ce qui s'est passé mais ça a
fait cet effet super est impossible à
reproduire et donc cette photo elle est
unique et je pourrai jamais la refaire
et c'est ça qui me plaisait et je me
suis donc passionné pour la photographie
argentique je voulais apprendre toutes
les techniques est en fait en argentique
on peut mélanger des produits chimiques
différents papiers et on peut arriver
avec la même feuille à plein de résultat
différent je m'amuse à faire ces
montages pour montrer qu'avec une photo
argentique on pouvait faire et bien du
bleu du sépia du coloré et et tous ces
différents détails qui qui me semblait
super créatif ça me permettait de voilà
de développer ma créativité et alors
même quand j'ai été jusqu'en alaska
comme sven pour faire des photos depuis
l'hélicoptère est bien je voulais pas
faire de numérique alors que en fait
c'est complètement débile de faire des
photos en argentique de sport parce que
déjà on peut pas faire deux séquences
son pouvoir faire tchac tchac tchac et
ensuite on voit pas ces photos donc on
ne sait pas si on a réussi aussi on a
raté si le mec il a risqué sa vie en
alaska pour rien ou pas
et quand bien même et bien dans les
capteurs j'étais là avec mon pentax avec
l'autofocus et j'essayais de faire la
mise au point que les doigts gelés et
j'étais vraiment fier de ramener ces
photos parce que pour moi elle était
vachement vachement plus belles
vachement le personnel et à c'est à
cette époque que j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser à toutes les techniques de
tirage ancien qui date du 17e 18e 19e
siècle parce que je voulais que mes
photos ressemble de moins en moins à des
photos mais pour devenir plus
universelle qu'elle ressemble le plus
possible à des peintures et il ya une
technique qui s'appelle brouille qui
consiste à faire disparaître sa photo
dans la chambre noire avec un produit
chimique la feuille redevient blanche
mais la gélatine se durcit et on utilise
cette gélatine comme la matrice d'une
lithographie et avec de la peinture et
de lancre à gravure et petit à petit en
tapant avec un pinceau on peut faire
réapparaître la photo donc la base est
réel l'événement est réelle mais la
graphie et un dessin une peinture est
alors bien sûr je vais personnes pour
m'apprendre l'art japonais tout seul et
ça marchait pas j'arrivais pas à faire
revenir ma photo et quand ça revenait
tous les détails dans les claires dans
les tons clairs disparaissent
j'avais plus aucune définition dans la
neige dans les nuages en voyait plus
rien je me suis dit c'est pas grave je
vais utiliser ça comme une force je vais
prendre des négatifs avec lesquelles
cette technique fonctionne le mieux
et c'est comme ça que j'ai fait ces
tirages broomhall qui permettent d'avoir
vraiment une peinture vachement plus
universel que une photo et c'est pas un
mec c'est pas la photo d'un mec qui
marche au canada dans la poudreuse c'est
l'idée de marché au canada dans la
poudreuse et c'est ça qui m'intéresse
c'est vachement plus ici on peut voir la
différence entre une photo
donc le témoignage d'un événement précis
et le brome oil qui est en fait le
dessin qui représente l'idée de faire du
snowboard et en poussant cette idée de
plus en plus loin je me suis dit mais
j'ai même pas besoin de faire de fautes
aussi je veux j'ai qu'à faire des
dessins à moi-même et c'est comme ça que
j'ai commencé à faire de la gravure je
me suis dit je vais prendre une photo
que moi j'ai prise et je vais la refaire
en gravure ça c'est une gravure sur
linoléum donc on fait des entailles dans
une plaque de linoléum pour recréer sa
photo ensuite on applique de la peinture
et en presse
et on obtient une gravure d'un d'une
photo inspiré d'une photo réelle et ça
ça m'a passionné je trouvais ça génial
et donc j'ai continué à faire ça j'ai
fait des gravures sur plaques de verre
ou avec une petite pointe en fer et ben
en fait on vient gratter la surface d'un
vernis et en abîmant le vernis et bien
on reproduit tous les tons de gris d'une
photographie qu'on utilise comme un
négatif géant et j'ai cassé ma vitre
mais c'est pas grave généreuse coach
après et on arrive à ce résultat là
c'est à dire que c'est c'est une photo à
la base donc c'est vraiment ce gars qui
saute et qui rappe twilight qui va là
bas mais c'est plus du tout une photo on
est d'accord et moi j'adore ces détails
très fin et très précis et c'est pour ça
que dans cette suite logique je me suis
mis à la gravure sur plaque de cuivre
qui a un peu l'étape ultime pour moi ça
représente et qui n'est pas décaler pas
fait d'école d'art ça représente
vraiment à l'étape ultime une gravure
c'est ce qu'on voit dans les musées et
moi je voulais qu'on voie le snowboard
dans les musées et donc c'est pour ça
que j'ai fait ces gravures sur plaque de
cuivre alors ça demande un temps infini
j'ai passé des mois pour faire ce truc
et ont donc on refait avec des petites
tailles une pointe en faire tous les
détails de la photo avec toutes les
toutes les gammes degré ensuite on met
de lancre qui s'en fit dans les tailles
ensuite on essuie la plaque jusqu'à ce
qu'ils aient plus d'encre et ensuite on
pressent et on transfère lancre sur la
feuille et on arrive à une gravure ça
s'appelle une eau forte et moi je
trouvais ça super beau est ce que
j'adore le plus c'est les bains voilà
les détails très fin et même si c'est un
événement réel et ben ça dépasse le réel
pour devenir plus imaginaires comme n'y
avait pas vraiment de limite à mon
imagination serge avait pas été formaté
par une école d'art qui m'aurait dégoûté
de l'art ou par une école de photo qui
me l'a dit la photo c'est comme ça il
faut faire comme si eh ben j'ai plein
d'idées comme ça j'ai testé les
milliards de trucs je voulais apprendre
toutes les techniques jusqu'à ce que
j'arrive à la conclusion que plutôt
d'utiliser photoshop pour travailler mes
photos que je scanne et et ben je
pouvais faire faute aux gens que moi
même sur le négatif
alors j'ai pris des loupes et des tout
petits outils et j'ai fait en fait
retravailler la lumière avec des
produits chimiques pour éclaircir
l'image ou avec deux langues pour
assombrir l'image et pourquoi pas écrire
dessus si je voulais vous faire une
bordure qui ressemble plus à une icône
religieuse pour arriver à des résultats
comme ça
et ça permet de vraiment s'exprimer même
si le médium est tout petit donc il faut
être très précis mais on peut quand même
transmettre des émotions qui sont
ressenties par le snowboarder sur cette
photo par exemple tous ces processus ont
fait que je me suis beaucoup démarquer
des autres photographes alors qu'il ya
quand même une culture de la
photographie argentique dans ce moment
mais mais pas tant que ça sur les photos
d'action et donc tous les tous les
magazines du monde entier m'ont contacté
pour faire des couvertures avec ses
photos et à une époque j'ai eu beaucoup
de succès avec ses photos et des
magazines du monde entier donc et ça
c'était pour moi une grande satisfaction
bien sûr d'avoir des photos en
couverture et en même temps ça me
faisait poser beaucoup de questions
c'est à dire que je me disais ok en fait
le monde part en vrille et nous on est
dans la neige à faire du snowboard à
s'amuser à sauter partout on s'en fout
complètement du reste des gens et on est
complètement égocentrique en fait c'est
ça qui m'a amené à faire mon premier
film et j'attendais qu'un cameraman de
snowboard montre en fait la réalité de
la vie des pros ce no border je voulais
qu'on voie le backstage toute la vraie
vie de ces gars là est ce film
n'arrivant pas je me suis bon balle et
mon gros tu t'y cole et donc j'ai acheté
une caméra à 5 50 balles sur le bon coin
je les collais sur mon appareil photo
comme ça je pourrais continuer à faire
mes photos et pendant quatre ans tout le
temps que je passais à faire des photos
eh ben je filmais en même temps il se
filme et touche filmer les soirées les
préparations les mecs qui tombe et ça
m'a permis de faire un espèce de super
cut un documentaire ou vraiment je
pouvait à loisir me moquer des
snowboardeurs donc de nous mêmes parce
qu'en fait on a on a toujours les mêmes
expressions pour dire que quelque chose
est incroyable
dans ces eaux
et donc c'est avec ces images là que
j'ai fait mon premier documentaire qui
s'appelle daytona beauty ou snowboarding
et que j'ai fait tout seul sur mon petit
ordinateur j'ai passé un an à faire le
montage j'ai appris à faire le montage
comme ça je les ai mis sur youtube et
salué un énorme succès plus d'un million
de vues sur internet parce que les gens
aient retrouvé beaucoup du coeur de ce
que nous on aime en tant que no border
et le film est vraiment fait comme une
dissertation de philosophie avec
introduction thèse antithèse synthèse
parce que moi je me posais beaucoup de
questions sur à quoi ça sert de faire du
snowboard
est ce que vraiment c'est beau est ce
que le fait que ce soit beau justifie
qu'on passe notre temps à faire ça et
pas à aider le reste de la planète
donc c'était voilà ça c'était mon coin
et documentaires et d'avoir fait ce film
ça m'a ouvert des portes et suite à
avoir fait ce film là au printemps
dernier on m'a proposé d'être le
réalisateur d'une énorme expédition au
pakistan une exposition freeride dans
des glaciers perdu au fin fond du
karakoram où on a passé trois semaines
avec toute notre équipe pour aller faire
le freeride une phase extrêmement raide
et donc ont attiré déluge pendant des
semaines avec nos la nourriture
lyophilisée que manger matin midi et
soir
on a dû passer un col qui était à 5600
mètres
c'est comme ça que je me suis retrouvé à
faire mon premier vrai film d' aventure
qui s'appelle à barbaste c'était pour
moi d'énormes responsabilités mais
j'avais aucune formation donc j'ai
appris tout seul à faire le logiciel de
montage professionnel l'étalonnage le
sound mix
heureusement j'avais des techniciens qui
m'ont appris mais j'étais très énervant
que les points les techniciens parce que
j'étais très pointu jouer tout contrôle
et jouer tout faire moi-même je voulais
pas déléguer donc je les remercie pour
leur patience et je vais vous montrer
maintenant la bande-annonce du film
le kanak
l' aventure la galère
les glaciers ben joie intense
mais qui peut l'appliquer
[Musique]
le kara korum l'exp la plus belle de ma
vie
[Musique]
ouais
on s'engage dans une boucle très
ambitieuse en passant par le mythique
col du scam là à 5600 personnes n'est
jamais allé faire du free ride par là
bas car le véritable objectif c'est la
tour nord biatch hirai verticale jamais
skié tout seul
à lui tout seul on né le 17 avril
nous on ne fait pas dans la dentelle et
pourtant j'adore la dentelle n'est pas
ici ici je suis une brute
on est des brutes
[Musique]
oh
ça
engagé comme objectif au nautisme est il
engagé
ce texte mois
[Musique]
ces peines [ __ ] partout et à la maintenir
à petiot la main son show cela on
chausse huawei [ __ ] je me suis
chauffeur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et donc avec ce film extraordinaire que
j'ai eu la chance de faire on a fait de
nombreuses projections et à chaque fois
après les projections il ya quelqu'un
qui vient me voir écrit me demande mais
comment on devient un photographe sur
serrières est quelqu'un me demande aussi
comment devient réalisateur de films
jeudi mais que j'en sais rien moi j'ai
pris une caméra j'ai fait un film
voilà et je pense que d'avoir deux pas
avoir eu cette formation à l'école et
d'avoir eu à prendre tous par moi même
j'ai fait beaucoup d'erreurs
j'ai fait des photos ratées en effet
plaint mais au moins c'était les miennes
et c'est comme ça que j'ai pu découvrir
ma propre personnalité mon propre style
dans mes activités
voilà je vous remercie merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]